fully solid fully defensive chess
okay he's actually giving up a pawn
dropping his queen back okay so there's
tension between the queens
i'll tell you he's slightly frowned
there he never normally gives anything
away on his camera but the bar does not
like minus his decision i'm trying to
understand this oh
magnus just uh suddenly reacting
yeah i'm trying to understand he's given
up a pawn but there's two different ways
that white can actually win a pawn right
now
he is shocked magnus crosses this was a
mouse was it a mouse maybe he meant to
put the bishop on that square
and also okay look at this white can win
a pawn in two different ways the top
computer suggestion is for the white
queen just to step up one square and
capture the pawn in front of it
that's a free pawn no compensation at
all for black that's a big advantage for
white or if white wants to be
extra kind of safe you can trade off the
queens and then remember that white
bishop is eyeing up a pawn black's h
pawn in the corner so you can win a pawn
in two different ways ivanka i think so
maybe we can start talking about that
queen move then in game three
what happened there was it a mouth slip
or or what happened
well
my first idea was to
um
was to play queen from e4 to e6
um
so i almost played it and then i became
a bit unsure and i thought i put the
queen back and i i kept thinking i mean
i think i sat there for like a minute
before i realized that i'd actually put
the queen on the wrong square because i
thought
i just
the queen was back um
and um i was thinking and then yeah i
noticed all of a sudden that it was this
move and
i was shocked by that obviously um
because the thing is queen e6 isn't even
a very good move uh
and i sort of realized that
eventually uh that i should probably
probably place play something else um
but um
yeah that was that was unfortunate um
since
without that without that move i don't
think the fourth game
uh happens yeah yeah we could see a big
reactions for you when you realized this
this wasn't the best move